au mois de septembre pour sécuriser la
piste cyclable
il n'était pas question d'enlever des
stationnements près du parc laurier
denis coderre avait donc tranché le
trottoir serait moins large
deux mois plus tard voici le résultat ce
première montréalaise un trottoir de 70
cm bienvenue aux unijambiste 70 cm donc
un mètre de moins que la grandeur
recommandé le chef de l'opposition
voulait que jean-pierre sur le parc
quand ses propres militants et ses
propres conseillers me traitait de tous
les noms quand je là quand je faisais
juste le regarder
à un moment donné c'est peut-être parce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont ils auraient
dû faire leur travail autrement qui
arrive avec un plat ultra original que
fait dans son sous sol que demander à
personne
lui n'a pas collaborent unis avec
l'arrondissement ni avec ses propres
services lorsqu'on arrive ici on
constate qu'effectivement le trottoir
n'est pas très large est difficile de
savoir si en général ils sont des
milliers à l'utiliser ou seulement
quelques uns on s'entend tous les deux
camps n'a rien n'est jamais venu là
c'est monsieur coderre ça c'est un
usager le qu'on n'a jamais vues sur ce
point-là 6400 utilisateurs utilisent la
piscine juste au nord ce trottoir là
était presque pas utiliser qui étaient
tellement importants qu'ils étaient pas
des glaces et l'hiver bien une pente
entre le parc et le trottoir l'eau du
parc ans à fons ramasse beaucoup se
croire c'est très difficile à diriger
avec beaucoup de sel avec beaucoup de
jeunes y est celui là ça va être encore
plus difficile à déneiger qu'une brosse
à dents de scie le dentaire le maire
estime qu'il en a assez parlé
là ça fait des mois des moines puis j'ai
décidé que c'est la clé puis c'est fini